et vous est-ce que vous parlez à votre
téléphone
je n'ai pas parlé au téléphone jeudi
parler à votre téléphone
c'est une vraie question je vous regarde
alors moi avant je parlais pas mon
téléphone
un peu comme ça mais je parlais pas mon
téléphone mais ça c'était avant avant
qu'il m'arrive
un petit incident qui a nécessité une
opération
une opération du coude alors c'était pas
grave c'est un pur gentil bien que avant
de rentrer en salle d'opération vous
imaginer plein de choses mais surtout
vous réfléchissez comment régler le
quotidien parce que vous savez bien vous
allez vous arrêter puis vous arrêtez
c'est jamais facile
enfin peut-être que vous vous avez le
temps de vous arrêter moi je sais pas si
c'est le temps qui manque aux l'envi
mais j'aime pas m'arrêter
alors là j'ai dû m'arrêter et j'avais
bien réfléchi qu'est ce que je dois
faire etc
j'avais imaginé bien sûr ressortir de
l'opération avec un bras bloqué ce que
j'avais pas imaginer c'est que j'allais
ressortir de l'opération avec un
cathéter est un bras bloqués et quand je
me suis retrouvé comme ça je me suis dit
ça va être moins facile ça va mettre
moins facile mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on remonte d'une salle d'opération
quand on arrive en chambre immédiatement
qu'est ce que vous faites
je me suis dit il faut que j'envoie des
mails pour dire je ne serais pas là donc
comment faire quand vous n'avez plus
bruns et là je me suis dit il me faut un
assistant et comme vous vous dites une
fois un assistant vous consacrez nestor
bien sûr il a versé tout votre enfant
s'il était là il avait l'air sérieux y
aller tout donc il vous faut nestor et
je me suis dit mais finalement j'ai un
assistant j'ai un assistant personnel
vous avez tous un assistant personnel
alors je reconnais que je n'avais pas
beaucoup utilisé jusque là mais pourquoi
pas alors vous pouvez lui donner tous
les noms que vous voulez il peut
s'appeler syrie si vous aimez les pommes
il peut s'appeler cortana il peut
s'appeler bixby il peut s'appeler il
peut s'appeler le mien s'appelle nestor
alors je parle à nestor alors vous
imaginez je reviens donc j'ai mon
cathéter j'ai mon bras subie en creux la
catastrophe
et puis je me dis quand même qu'est ce
que je vais faire et là je me dis bon il
faut que j'envoie ses mails alors je lui
demande
il est là pour ça quand même il a mon
service en plus il a une empreinte de
cali les cas mon service donc j'ai dit
cheikh nestor envoyé un mail agent pour
lui dire cher jean virgules mon rapport
final aura quelques jours de retard virl
etc
et là je me dis non non non
il va me croire mais enfin comme je suis
des fois en retard il va se douter de
quelque chose donc il faut que j'envoie
une photo une photo ça parle beaucoup
mieux alors j'ai dit pas de problème je
vais envoyer photos fait un pas de
problème voilà donc je pose mon
téléphone en mode self y est je me dis
attention
souriez qu'est ce qu'on dit en fait pour
prendre une photo
je me dis tive rien dit alors je demande
jeudi stern et store quelle est la
commande vocale pour déclencher
l'appareil photo c'est bon je les hardis
cher nestor smile rien c'est une
histoire d'accent jamais store smael
toujours rien que là ça vous énerve un
peu je le reconnais che comme vous il ya
cette courbe d'apprentissage dont on
parle pas il faut commencer à apprendre
à parler aux machines elle me comprend
pas il me comprenait elle me comprend
pas j'aurais dû pouvoir lui dire
clic-clac j'aurais dû poule en chine
tout le monde sait que ça veut dire
prendre une photo bon alors comme smile
ça marchait pas je reprends la pause
puis je dis ok je sais je vais utiliser
le deuxième os je lui dis oui ce qui est
là ça prend bien c'est une histoire
vécue
donc oui enfin voila je suis
impressionné par le travail de nestor
avoue le sait tout ça la preuve
et vous dites mais quand même en facile
s'envoyer des mails envoyés des messages
il appeler mes contacts qui m'a rendu
bien service commun voilà mais je sors
de l'hôpital et je me dis voilà j'arrive
à la maison j'ai encore un peu cabossée
jeu et si je sortais la borne que j'ai
acheté il ya quelques temps
cette borne dites intelligentes qui est
censé avoir nestor à l'intérieur alors
je sens ma borne jusque là je n'avais
pas sorti pour une raison simple c'est
qu'elle parlait anglais mais pas le même
en quelques mois on se comprenait pas 9a
le par le français elle a appris très
vite d'ailleurs elle parle le français
mais là encore pas tout à fait développé
pour la 6 donc la pause etc
puis je me dis on va faire des tests
est-ce que nestor est capable de faire
plus avec moi plus franchement plus qu'à
faire un appel ou enfin j'ai dit là on
était en gros c'est du basique avec moi
il n'ya pas d'écran j'ai placé une
technologie dans ma maison en 2018
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'écran
et là ça devient quand même intéressant
pourquoi pour la première fois on repose
quelque chose dans un salon qui est pas
vraiment me villain moi je trouve
monstres magnifiques et puis qu'est ce
qu'on va faire avec nestor on va le
partager parce que il est au centre de
la famille
c'est dire que ma famille n'a pas de
chance je vous retrouve toujours des
trucs bizarres donc on à nestor et puis
on a commencé à discuter avec nesta
alors qu'est ce qu'on lui demande un
essor la première chose qu'on lui
demande évidemment c'est des
informations parce qu'on dit waouh c'est
plein de choses on lui demande la météo
c'est la météo
il sait la météo à martini aujourd'hui
il sait lama la météo a marqué ni demain
il sait quelle heure il est maintenant à
new york qui s'est plaint de tricks bon
à l'ag internet aussi il m'épate pas
mais c'est plein d'autres choses et je
me suis dit qu'est ce que je peux lui
faire faire je peux le dire
imaginez toujours à la maison je teste
le canapé j'avais plus de cathéters mais
bon voilà quoi
alors qu'est ce qui peut faire il te
brancher la télé ah non ça il faut pas
le faire par contre qu'il peut faire
c'est de diffuser des programmes télé
nestor mais moi ma série préférée saône
et flix et c'est parti d'après lui la
suivante facilement sinon alors c'est
pas mal il interagit avec ma télé et
puis j'ai dit nestor allume la lumière
et par la lumière
donc je me dis nestor commence à faire
des choses intéressantes
il nous donne des informations il peut
jouer différents médias il peut
évidemment faire un peu de domotique ça
commence à être intéressant est-ce qu'on
peut aller plus loin je me disais bon
quand même
je suis enseignante est ce que je
pourrais imaginer ce n'est ce temps pour
l'éducation mais bon j'étais mal en
point réfléchir c'était compliqué
j'étais toujours dans mon salon alors
j'ai fait ce qu'on doit faire finalement
j'ai prêté ma technologie mais le traité
c'était facile de qu'on était tous
ensemble autour de cette technologie est
franchement les enfants poser les
questions que moi j'avais jamais posée
que fait la petite souris des dents
kendrick holt
j'admets que j'étais un peu tendu sur la
réponse quand même pas me raconter des
trucs
si jamais vous lui demanderez une
réponse fin j'étais surpris je dis merci
merci nestor ou la pas casser un mythe
qui me coûte cher d'ailleurs et pour
l'éducation et toujours ce canapé
j'avais mon fils à côté qui se fait ses
devoirs et puis soudain je l'entends
dire sans 2377 plus 34000 je me retourne
faisant bien sûr que nestor a donné la
réponse fuse mais tu triches jeu quand
même j'ai dû qu'un peu je triche pas je
vérifie mais il avait raison
qu'est ce qu'il avait fait il avait fait
ses additions colonnes vous rappeler on
additionne ont même retenu on redescend
il avait fait tout ce travail et à la
fin toujours je dois vérifier de tête
évidemment si la réponse est correct et
au lieu de me le demandais de me voir
tapoter vous rappelez il l'a demandé et
c'est lui qui a eu cette idée de l'usaj
qu'on peut faire de cette technologie
c'est un usage de dire on peut être plus
autonome on peut amener les enfants plus
d'autonomie
alors ça veut pas dire plus de temps ne
vous entend pas ce que c'est mais
étudiants me le dise oui plus
d'autonomie on vous voit venir l'épreuve
c'est juste parce que vous savez pas les
réponses vous nous dites pas vous nous
faites chercher c'est parce que vous
voulez plus trop travailler vous fait
travailler les autres non c'est pas ça
c'est juste que vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on doit amener les
enfants des compétences qui vont amener
à des métiers qui aujourd'hui n'existe
peut-être pas encore mais peut-être que
ce serait bien qu'on les amène à
utiliser les outils qui aujourd'hui
existe donc c'est vrai que là il ya
quelque chose à faire déjà chez vous de
mettre vos enfants
n'hésitez pas à leur prêter votre
smartphone je le dis un an public et
filmer mon dieu laissez leur
s'approprier cette technologie pour
jouer ils vont le faire facilement
je pense que nous avons un rôle à faire
c'est de leur apprendre comment utiliser
ces technologies pourraient être des
professionnels
donc je me disais ok donc il a acquis un
peu d'autonomie comment ce que je
pourrais utiliser ce truc donc
j'enseigne au niveau tertiaire
je me voyais mal leur dire l'addition
colonnes vérifier la limite le prof de
maths aurait pu faire les cas des
équations et voilà mais même des matchs
au niveau tertiaire si vous n'avez pas
un tableau blanc c'est compliqué
donc là je me suis dit quelles sont les
choses qu'on pourrait faire faire et
c'est lui qui a refait il s'est ainsi pu
me dit voilà je vais demander un instant
la vie du renard j'étais bien assuré
qu'il lui demandait nestor est pas moi
la longévité du renard ou est ce qu'il
vit c'est petit et ses voyages en a pris
les choses
la seule chose que n'avait pas nestor
c'est une fête à dire non donc on
continue on se dit voilà comment ce
qu'on peut le prendre
est ce qu'on doit le mettre en classe
est-ce que cet outil là il va pouvoir
nous servir pour l'éducation
mais moi je pense il suffit d'inventer
des usages c'est à nous professionnels
d'imaginer les usages dont on va pouvoir
faire
que vous aimiez ou pas l'interface vocal
aujourd'hui manifestement vous l'aimez
pas encore beaucoup
l'année prochaine je reviens pas je
refais le même sondage ça va augmenter
il y aura plus de choix
ce qu'on nous annonce et moi je crois
c'est tout ce qu'on me raconte c'est que
ça va révolutionner le monde presque
autant que le smartphone si ce n'est
plus donc je me rappelle en 2007 quand
steve jobs nous disait je vais rien
inventé une manière de communiquer chez
au point quand même il a changé quelque
chose dans mes comportements
aujourd'hui c'est le local qui va
changer quelque chose dans vos
comportements dans vos comportements à
tous alors vous allez me dire oui mais
elle est là nestor là chez elle qu'est
ce qu'on va faire avec ça
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'imaginer
nestor me retrouve mon téléphone quand
je pars le matin ch à la bourre fassin
m'avait surpris quand même voulu dit
nestor où est mon téléphone un peu
affolés comme ça vous sentez et
qu'est-ce qui fait et dit voulez vous
que je fasse ce n'est votre téléphone
mais il fait mieux que faire sonner
votre téléphone
il fait un truc que personne peut faire
il a augmenté le volume du téléphone
avant de le faire sonner
voilà nestor le tester c'est l'adopter
je reviens en classe et finalement cette
ressource que j'ai à disposition
c'est un outil jeudi qu'on arrête de
croire que c'est autre chose qu'un outil
c'est une ressource à disposition et
comme toutes les ressources que vous
avez à disposition dans une classe elle
va pas être utilisé tout le temps elle
doit pas être utilisé pour tous elle va
être utilisée quand elle ajoute de la
valeur
donc il faut réfléchir quand est ce que
cette technologie là peut ajouter de la
valeur et c'est à nous d'imaginer les
usages où on peut se faire aider par les
enfants donc vous quand vous regardez
comment je fonctionne cette bande vous
pouvez lui demander plein de choses
qu'elle sait déjà c'est à dire tous cas
sur internet
c'est déjà assez bas instincts comme
truc mais ce que vous pouvez faire aussi
c'est le définir un périmètre d'action
où elle va donner des réponses qui vous
sont propres
vous pouvez lui faire dire ce que vous
avez envie qu'elles disent à peu près
mais vous pouvez monter des quizz vous
pouvez faire des jeux qui vous sont
spécifiques et là ça devient extrêmement
intéressant est ce que j'imaginais parce
que on a quand même des programmes
extraordinaires chez nous on a des
échanges linguistiques et moi quand j'ai
vu mon jeune à qui arrivait avec un
haut-valaisan qui parle est super bien
français comme mon fils par les super
bien allemand il était dépité face à
nous il avait avait parlé dans toutes
les langues qu'ils connaissaient mais
l'autre aérien compris idem et c'était
nous les adultes y allons avec eux pour
essayer de démêler tout ça et de les
rendre un peu plus à l'est à ce qu'est
ce qu'ils étaient mal à l'aise
moi j'imagine que si on leur donne
soudain nestor au milieu des sorts
killer traduit nestor qui prononce
correctement ce que voulait dire la
correctement pour l'autre
nestor devient un interlocuteur qui
permet à l'adulte de reculer et à les
laisser à prendre en autonomie donc des
exemples comme ça il y en a plein il
suffit de les imaginer mais c'est pas
que dans l'éducation qui va falloir les
imaginez bien sûr que la réflexion par
le questionnement bien sûr qu'il va
falloir poser les bonnes questions
si vous voulez avoir une réponse
intelligente il faut poser la bonne
question et pour poser la bonne question
il faut avoir le bon vocabulaire l'école
encore beau jodoin a quand même c'est
pas fini pour lesquelles ça veut dire
qu'on va devoir apprendre aux enfants
que ce qu'il ya dans nestor pas s'il ya
un truc dans nestor à ça j'ai les
emballages mais intérieure et un truc
c'est pas de la magie même si beaucoup
de l'aide se ressemblent ce n'est pas de
la magie c'est de la machine et on doit
apprendre aux enfants comment fonctionne
la machine la magie la main chez nous la
magie c'est égal on doit lui apprendre
comment ça fonctionne quand on lui a
appris comment un robot se déplacer et
comment ce que lui pouvait faire en
sorte que leur bosse chez les lignes on
doit lui apprendre comment programmer
ces machines et moi quand je programme
mon four à la maison j'aime bien les
alhazen dedans chipa électronicienne je
mets ma peine cuisinière donc quand je
programme une borne pour qu'elle fasse
quelque chose pour lequel elle a été
dédiée je suis pas informaticienne jeu
juste un usager et ses usages vous tous
qui êtes dans la salle chacun dans vos
métiers
il va falloir les imaginer les imaginer
pour qu'ils créent de la valeur est
partout il y en aura vous imaginez vous
mettez nestor sur une borne et il peut
vous répondre dans plein de langues
ça ferait pas mal quand même ou alors il
sait tout la taille du 44e président des
etats-unis c'est plein de choses donc
l'ajout challenge un petit peu bientôt
très bientôt vous aurez des bornes
elles seront partout vous allez les voir
elles seront chez vous peut-être à
l'épaule en tout cas dans plein
d'endroits qu'elle à la première
question vous allez poser à la borne
alors à mon arc très parlée
[Applaudissements]